I got some sad news today we lost one of
our own our own human beings oh you guys
watch a terrace house on Netflix cuz I
think is a pretty cool dating show heard
of in everyone oh you guys should watch
terrorists house Harris I was like what
love is a battlefield so no terrace
house it's a so it's like good
it's like real world like back in the
day it's like a dating don't know one
single right
everyone's single and then you just live
like love island yeah I love Island but
it's not so trashy it's it's a Japanese
show oh yeah it's way better it's what's
with the Japanese show it's a Japanese
dating
I only tune in for the trash though all
right this one doesn't actually have
trash it's just a bunch of normal as
people um but unfortunately one of the
cast members Hana Kimura she is 22 years
old and a pro wrestler is yeah a
wrestler yeah they have a lot of cool
types of people on the show just kind of
like you huh hmm from this site from
this thing oh look we we lost her so
they're not giving details of her cause
of death but they always they're they're
tying in corona cyber bullying has
something yeah because I don asleep ink
that it is a yeah I think it's suspected
with reality shows and suicide because
there's not proper care mental health
care before and after for the level of
theme they get overnight oh yeah there's
a regular people's yeah and because
everyone wants to comment on them and
it's edited in a certain way yeah people
look like heroes and villains and you
know for people to take things out of
context yeah there's three people from
Leviathan kill themselves boy real the
biggest stars - holy [ __ ] black mirror
and the host that's [ __ ] down - can
you still watch it
in some parts for me because like I'm
watching old seasons and I know like
that one of them lives just makes funny
jokes no no that's a narrator he didn't
kill himself he's hilarious
but there's a female host that is like
she comes out when someone gets
eliminated from the show so she's like
love islanders you have been eliminated
by the audience one at 1% is going home
tonight and then she like says she
breaks them but it's a thing guy so they
say they give proper mental health care
to them after the show but they don't
look like so you're supposed to hook you
up with like a therapist
yeah so you for a little while after the
show did you stop making sure that they
need to get mental help I'll do those so
we when we create a shady agents the guy
that created he's a psych clinical
psychologist and that's is his actual
job before we before bringing people on
reality shows and off he has to brief
them and then debrief yeah yeah the
slightest reality TV show it could be a
shark tank it could be the theme where
the lost luggage like people just aren't
ready to handle that kind of theme if
like that episode pops off cuz it goes
like globally you know and like people
like they are they're super mega famous
all of a sudden and there's like a lot
of haters and on a smaller scale YouTube
requires like you receive the hate yeah
then amplify that by like a thousand
yeah in her case um it sucks even more
because she is somewhat of an
entertainer and you would assume that an
entertainer would be equipped receptive
to this kind of stuff she's ready right
she's equipped for it right cuz you
think her skin yeah she's a she's a
wrestler and stereotypically like I
knows wrestlers and female wrestler we
have a friend who's a female wrestler
there's a persona involved they're
strong yeah they're there they really
have a thick skin literally and you know
emotionally but like the thing is even
that you know as someone as tough as
that was still hurt by all the negative
comments and what ended up happening was
there was a little incident in the show
where I guess one of her cast mates I
shrank one of her clothing or whatever
and then you know she basically kind of
hit on
and like went off on him or like but she
was looked like a [ __ ] or a bad girl
right obviously people reacted to that
and you're so [ __ ] whatever and
talking all this [ __ ] and she posted a
photo of herself saying I love you live
a happy long life I'm sorry yeah yes I'm
sad and it's just her and her kitty and
I was the last thing she posted and yeah
it's kind of sad because now Japan is
seriously considering and talking about
actions against cyberbullying hmm yeah I
used to be I think so they're like in
this new world you know we have to
navigate through this whole like
phenomenon of the Internet and she goes
we have to learn how to conduct
ourselves well based off of this new
thing that we're trying to figure out
what exactly is cyber bullying is it
just any negative comment or it's just
like straight-up blatant like insults I
think it's all the above yeah anything
that you take in and it affects you yeah
but you could be like you're stupid to
go [ __ ] die you know what's crazy
that YouTube doesn't know that I didn't
even realize they do in terms of
cyberbullying because I uploaded a video
the other day and I didn't notice there
was a tab that was marked that was like
oh hold off on potentially offensive
comments yeah and I didn't even know
that was there
one day I [ __ ] checked which which
one I only have like one or two and I
clicked online potentially offensive
comment and one was just like [ __ ] so
let's say you post something on YouTube
right someone goes this video wasn't as
good as your last is that considered I
think that whatever we can use in the
real world such as defamation slander
hate speech harassment right I think
that those will apply on text the thing
is when people are anonymous the things
that they would say in real live Liam
most people will not say in your face
[ __ ] you Tim yep even if they really
felt it but when they're hiding behind a
screen in a different persona with a
different with the avatar of a [ __ ]
Sonic the Hedgehog or whatever like they
could say [ __ ] you Tim but add immediate
green like maybe some of the guys that
actually said it in one of your comments
they wouldn't actually say I had
exact same thing happened there was a
guy that was leaving consistent hater
comments on each one of my youtube
videos right and let's say the [ __ ]
name was like I don't know much a man
right got to the point where if I saw a
video without a hater comment from Macho
Man I'm like yeah yeah right so I had a
meet and greet in Vancouver at some Club
this dude comes up to me he's like hey
man I'm Macho Man I was like what the
[ __ ] and he's like oh I'm actually a big
fan bro I just like talking [ __ ] and
then we [ __ ] took a pic oh my god
that's how it all is I think that needs
to be repercussions because they don't
know what they do yeah especially if the
person is going through
like if you're youtuber like I don't
know a lot of artists and people like
that are creatives like a lot of
emotional ups and ups and downs and then
you like sometimes they catch you on an
off day like most times I'm like
whatever haters whatever but sometimes
there's an off day and it's just like
this wave and it's like I don't even
feel like I could be a person right now
just don't know what people are going
through it yeah and people forget that
because we're in their homes and and and
they're watching us and they know us
well and they know our inside jokes well
that they don't realize that I don't
know you right so then that when you say
something and you're trying to be funny
number one the context on text you can't
feel it you don't know it don't know you
don't know how are you saying it exactly
so I was doing a live and then one of
the people in there were asking me for
like some relationship advice or
whatever and I'm talking and during the
whole thing this guy goes look at Joe
talking about relationship advice when
he doesn't even have a girlfriend right
now mm-hmm
and I was like why would you say that
right and then he goes oh I thought you
enjoyed jokes and funny stuff like what
happened I do enjoy jokes but what did
you say that but for him he thought that
was hilarious right he's a he's a devout
fan he comes in every single time but he
was just sure that he knows you as
negativity he thinks it's hilarious you
gotta hit it with the loljk guys we
can't see how [ __ ] dumb let me know
so if that was in person maybe it was
well executed it would have been a good
Rose differ and funny but context people
like we don't know you so when you say
certain things it could literally come
off as someone who thinks that because
there
are trolls and we don't know how to
differentiate that yeah we don't how to
differentiate the person that really
says [ __ ] you Tim versus [ __ ] you Tim
right right and there's always there's
mob mentality too so it's like people
all read through your comments may see
like a bunch of people hating on you for
one thing they start to like just join
in and they don't even maybe know the
whole thing of what's going on but I
just jump in that's one reason why like
I don't usually delete negative comments
unless it's in the first hour yeah the
first couple comments are just someone
talking [ __ ] I'll get rid of those just
in case of the bandwagon mentality and
luckily one thing that is dope that
YouTube did is they do the whole like
you know you can pin a comment you can
heart a comment cuz those will always
show up at the top and I feel like you
know everybody it's when you click the
video you go straight to the comments
right so I feel like those first handful
of comments you read kind of influenced
what yeah how you react to the video you
want to show the audience what you
actually look at and what you know
because they so they just want your
attention mm-hmm and some people just
respond to the negative ones so they it
incentivizes other people jellied
negative power yeah so the first hour of
a video upload I I read the comments and
I heart the one like I heart pretty much
all of them unless it's like someone
being a troll and I'll respond to most
of them as long as it's not somebody
being a troll just to like say like hey
I'm reading and also good people are
people who I mean I get DMS from like
your guys's fans were like they're like
hey can you tell them to unblock me I
don't know why he did that
yeah whenever is the funny thing is when
they asked me to block down ask Bart or
David I blocked them to immediately
reply his blog reason why you're blocked
whenever someone's like hey man um when
they hit me from something else and like
why did you block me or like Mike or why
did your why did Chia block me I'm like
bro if Chia blocked you you probably
said something annoying this book so
it's not our job to give you education
on where you messed up socially that's a
lesson you got to learn and maybe you
know you you had great intentions who
knows you wanted to be funny whatever
but you shot your shot and it didn't
work out so you got blocked man it's not
really the person's job to teach you
anything but this is the this is our end
right this is our experience as being in
front of camera and we kind of signed up
to this but on reality TV like you just
said
when they go on they're not ready for
this type of fame and abuse and they
weren't they didn't know that after the
show people would be receiving slander
almost on a daily basis where for us
it's like unless you went viral
most of our fame quote-unquote was like
slow growth so we had a [ __ ] you here
and there now I have a [ __ ] you every
day and people don't know that a lot of
times the reality TV shows they can skew
the storyline - yeah so they first they
write the show how they think it's gonna
be then once they get all the videos
then they're like oh wait there's a way
juicier story so what whatever she might
not even have been a [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna be more way more entertaining of a
watch to make her a [ __ ] and they'll do
it that way yeah the crazy part for
reality shows is that they're not in
control of their content whereas for us
we are in control so it's like if we did
something say we did something bad in
one of our videos or whatever we can do
an apology video and we on the same
platform with the same amount of
exposure to try and fix things if that
were to happen but for them it's like
they don't get to say their piece on the
exact show they have to go on another
platform which may not have the same
exposure level and so then for a lot of
people like that apology or whatever
their piece has never heard everyone see
it yeah so they're always viewed as the
villain yeah bro I didn't even realize
how like I knew it was all manipulated
in a certain way on reality TV shows
right but I didn't realize how much it
is twisted around because like I was
talking to um we're not one of the like
a couple Jersey Shore people and she
said one time they literally took a
snippet of a conversation she was having
with someone else on the phone took that
soundbite and use it for another fun
conversation to twist it to make it seem
like she was arguing with someone else
about something totally different dude
yeah we just plug big mood we had a girl
from 90-day fiance on there she's on the
current season which one Devin Devin
Clara no she loves she follows all of us
bro the FATA dude
yeah she loves JK she says she watched
JK while she was going into labor
Wow yeah yeah she's a shout-out to Devin
she's a sweetheart
dad to Devin she dates that she's
married to a Korean guy yeah yeah yeah
so she's like they're stories great too
like it's a real love story and they're
one of the non weird ones that I like
yeah and she gets tons of hate not just
from the cyber bullies but from other
cast members because they just get all
jealous
that's why cuz she's there nor the most
normal couple yeah yeah liked all the
cloud chasing like other people they
just get really like caddy and stuff
she's like I don't get it I'm trying to
get rose on here so I get Big Ed on mine
20:22
cuz Devin's 23 and this girl's 22 that's
so young like you don't really like
you're not all the way developed on who
you are you haven't like really formed
yeah I really can't blame her because
when we were 23 we started YouTube we
were trying to fight people for their
negative comments yeah I would be like
meet me at the [ __ ] park and I was
mad I would every single time someone
had something to say I'll buy your plane
ticket I was broke as hell my head wants
[ __ ] free travel so I could beat your
ass cuz I can't go there I got work but
there are people like you know women in
wrestling like Ronda Rousey who came out
and she said there are no words that
could possibly yield this wound right
because I think she's been a victim of
everyone knows how this feels like and
she's it's cyber bullying is a very real
and growing threat to you us as a
society even a straws weight can be the
one to break a camel's back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]